Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast from Monday.
Uh,
July 15th,
2013.
Barry Sanders.
Dan Marino.
Um,
how are ya?
How's it going?
I know the podcasts late.
I don't understand why you guys feel like you actually have and not all you guys
just to feel,
yeah,
actually feel that you know when this podcast is supposed to come about,
you know,
it's called the Monday morning podcast.
Why isn't it around on Monday morning?
Well,
let me ask you this.
I made that fucking song led.
Zepplin did that.
Hey,
mom has said where you going?
I'm going to make you
click [inaudible] dot.
[inaudible] remember that shit?
That ain't me.
That song's called black dog.
It's not about a black dog.
He never says black dog.
Okay.
I don't know the dates.
A black dog walked in the fucking studio,
right?
Wasn't wearing a hoodie.
Okay.
So nobody shot it.
John Bonam didn't have to stand his ground.
Alright,
the fucking dog came walking in
and uh,
you know,
they just called the song black dark.
So there you go.
The Monday morning podcast.
I do it Monday mornings when I wake up,
when I'm in town.
I was on a fucking plane this Monday morning flying from fucking from Boston.
A W people not be a h u Midwestern conch thinking you could do a Boston accent.
It's boff a w Boston,
the red sox.
S AWX like saw like in a shot down a tre.
Can you,
can you figure that out?
Damage to green jeans when you're not out there planting food for the fucking
country.
Well,
can you all right then I was just asking,
you don't have to grab you a little shoulder straps on your overalls.
By the way.
What is that pocket for between your man tits?
What do you stick in there?
How you remote control?
You stick something in there for wetland.
She goes,
scrub your nails.
Um,
fuck was I talking about?
Oh yeah,
I was flying back from Boston and uh,
I got upgraded is a classic example of cold lotion.
Everybody.
All right,
I'm in the back of the plane with the fucking animals,
right?
All of us back there clamoring around.
You know,
we all sucked at math so maybe we were good at math.
We just want good at fucking,
you know,
getting along with people.
Which one of those is one of the keys?
Main keys to success people.
You gotta be a good shit.
I care how smart you are.
You gotta be somebody that people want to be around.
Alright.
Fairburn.
Einstein was a cunt,
you know,
just stick a,
how many more Japanese people would be around today?
That's so bad.
I'm sorry,
I can never get past that.
He made the bomb.
Okay.
He didn't have to do it,
you know?
Okay.
Oh,
it's fucking people asking them to make the God thing.
They did not adore it.
He could've just been like,
yeah,
I don't know how to make something like that.
You know,
you're going to have to earn this one there.
Sargent Riker.
Um,
all right.
I'd probably offended at least nine different races at this point.
Let's,
uh,
let's keep going here.
I know there's a point in here somewhere,
so I'm flying back.
So like I,
I'm in the back of the plane.
Right,
okay.
With the people who say what they feel to their boss.
The people sucked at math.
The people will fucking knocked up somebody that they're not in love with.
You know,
I dunno.
I Dunno what we did to deserve to be in the back of that fucking plane.
All right?
But we're back there and all of a sudden I get a little fucking tap on the
shoulder and says,
Mister
[inaudible] [inaudible] there's a spot up in our first class cabin.
Is this space available?
You've been upgraded,
you know,
and what do I say?
Do I say,
no,
I'm not going.
I'm staying with my people.
You know,
the downtrodden,
the mentally challenged,
not number,
uh,
mentally challenged kind of way.
Just like in a,
that guy's not all their kind of way,
you know?
Huh?
Do I fucking hang in there?
Like William Wallace is say,
pull out my end trails trying to drag me into first class and say,
no,
I'm not going.
I'm going to stare in my ground.
I'm going to stay here.
When the fucking the,
uh,
the,
the main cabin,
I'll let the cut the main fucking cabin.
Right.
Like you feeling like,
oh,
this is the main,
this is the shit.
I'm in the main,
I'm VIP.
No you're not.
She call it the fucking corral or something.
Like the stock aid.
Anyways.
Did I stay with my people?
No,
I didn't.
I sold them out.
I said fuck this.
I'm out.
Like the leader of a union spoken with some guy that smells like clam sauce.
There's another group.
Um,
and I go up to the front.
So I went from my fucking knees and my chest
highlights magazine.
Right.
Right in my face.
You know,
whatever they have there,
the Sky Mall,
you know,
cause you want to buy a fucking Mickey mouse,
a ashtray,
whatever the hell they have slash iPod charger.
That's my joke that me and Joe always do.
Our joke I should say about Bobby Kelly,
whatever gadget he has,
where it always ends with and it,
it charges my iPod.
I just bought a fucking guilt out.
It goes clockwise counter clockwise and it charges my iPhone.
Kig um,
I'm sorry.
So anyways,
so I go up to him.
I'm fucking excited as hell.
Going to sit in first class with all the big boys,
all the blood money.
All right,
everybody up there,
you know,
some bearded fellow with curly cues and diamonds under his hat.
I'm upfront,
I'm upfront with the blue bloods,
people who own horses just to all them because they think they're cute cause
they got to go fucking till the land.
That's how you say it.
So I get up my seat.
Don't think chuck was,
I was a very front row seat.
You can't,
you can't put your shit on to the person in front of you.
So I had to look for an overhead compartment space people,
if you could just put your bags in the overhead compartments,
we could expedite the boarding process.
We're trying to have an on time departure.
Um,
they all say the same thing and I fly all the Orange Airlines,
I horror around.
Um,
anyways,
so I fucking get up there and I sit down in my first class fucking cabin seat.
It's six 50 in the morning flight.
All right.
And I am a nice giant pillow.
I have a nice blanket FirstClass everything's Nice and you know,
pay for it.
All those poor saps back in the main cabin.
You know,
some lady going into Labor three months in because her knees is so fucked up
fucking up to her chin,
they don't care.
Okay.
When she has a little three pound babies,
we fly over the Rockies,
they don't care.
They don't give a fuck to them.
That's just another three pound animal to stuff in the back of the fucking
plane.
And at this point,
I don't care because I'm selfish.
I'm about me.
I'm up front,
I'm rubbing elbows with bankers,
you know,
I'm the only person up there without cufflinks,
standing out like I shouldn't be at the party,
but there's nothing they could say about.
So anyways,
I probably got two hours sleep,
which is the best way to get on a plane when you have a long flight.
Okay.
That is the all natural way of knocking yourself out rather than,
than taking some designer drug that's going to put your liver in a full Nelson,
you know,
maybe choke it out and give hammer in another seven hammer fist before that UFC
ref can slide over.
You know my only complaint about the UFC,
you know,
when was the last time somebody got knocked out and then didn't get an
additional four wet prep prep,
prep prep,
miss the fucking guys going.
I've never understood that aspect of ultimate fighting.
The fucking guy is out.
You could see these out and if you don't know he's out the entire crowd going,
oh it doesn't let you know he's out laying on the ground.
You know you fall down whenever you get knocked out.
It's funny cause like your legs crossed,
like you're watching television,
like enjoying your day off and then your arms.
They always like to kind of moving like Brock and back.
Like don't even know if he noticed that.
They always like go up.
Like you're still in fighting mode and,
but there's sort of like shaking like a,
I dunno,
like your legs are like drilled into the ground in Europe you'll hear toy and
somebody just flicked your head fucking e and what have you seen the shit.
So anyway,
anyway,
I haven't gotten onto that.
So anyways,
so I sit down there and I'm just like,
all right,
all right.
Oh right.
That's your liver shit.
You don't want to do that.
All right.
If you want to sleep on a flight,
just don't go to sleep.
Don't sleep the night before you flight.
I mean,
I'll fucking easy as that.
How Lazy Are you?
Okay?
Did you get that from your parents?
I mean,
well,
what's wrong with you?
I don't even think you should be listening to this podcast right now.
I think you should sit down,
have a little quiet time to figure out what the fuck is wrong with you.
I'm seriously repulsed by you right now if you'll,
if you fit into the definition of this.
All right?
So you just don't go to sleep.
So that's what I did.
I stayed out with fucking knew the pride in new works,
Paul Versey and uh,
I got two hours of sleep.
I drove my rented Kia,
um,
back to budget
and uh,
yeah,
what have I get on the fucking plane?
So I'm just going to go to sleep and I go to press the button to recline my seat
and my seat is broken.
It won't reply.
All right?
I got upgraded to first class in my spot.
My seat would recline and right there people,
cause there's a lot of confusion out there,
right there.
That is a classic example of some cold lotion.
Okay?
They're doing something nice for you.
But then there's an awful experience
evolved,
right?
Look up the definition because I'm sick of people sending me shit on Twitter
going,
oh,
you know,
this guy sent me when I went to this summer league and a watch my,
Portland Trailblazers,
but they lost to the Lakers.
That's some cold lotion.
Now what is it?
The Lakers didn't say,
hey,
we're going to fucking,
uh,
we're gonna lose on purpose tonight.
You know,
I dunno what the fuck you talking about,
sir?
So anyways,
now I'm fucking sleep and upright.
He now though,
I swear to God,
those God damn
chairs on airplanes,
uh,
just unforgiving.
First of all,
the fuselage is just far away from your head that is going to kill your neck if
you try and lean your head on it.
So then you get the pillow and the pills a piece of shit,
front or back of the plane.
The feathers just scatter.
Especially when you've got a big head like mine,
he can't get that.
Then you try to turn to the side.
All right.
You've tried to turn and lay it at an angle and then he got the,
uh,
the armrest,
which is,
feels like a fucking pistol stuck and you side.
Oh,
it's the worst.
You know,
I just threw the blanket over my head because I forgot my eye mask.
And uh,
did you see Superman and eye mask?
Um,
sorry.
whatever.
I just wanted to give you an example of what fucking cold lotion is or look it
up on the urban dictionary.
They gave a great explanation of what it is.
I'm tired of fucking correct.
And people on Twitter tighter that you could tell it on three shows this weekend
screaming my brains out,
cause I don't know how to write a joke.
I said like Peter Brady right now.
Um,
I'm sick of that on Twitter.
And then I'm also sick of the fucking,
uh,
people who go first.
World problems.
All right though.
That's,
that's the latest.
And the,
the,
the lists that I'm beginning for Twitter hack.
All right,
what do we have so far?
We have anything that begins with that feeling when that moment when or if you
go,
wait,
what?
Right.
I want the last such and such time of my life back.
I just threw up a little bit in my mouth.
All of these,
you've heard thousands of fucking times get,
for some reason a select 90% of people on Twitter continued to use them as if
this still funny.
The same fucking people would go out to go see a comedian and if they did the
same shit that they already saw him do on TV,
they'd be like,
the show sucked,
you know?
And they go on Twitter and they fucking hack it up.
I know being harsh and you guys cause you just civilians,
but if you want to enter the wonderful world of joke writing,
you need to step up your fucking gay.
Why don't you try to find your own voice on Twitter and 180 words,
the fucking letters or less,
whatever it is.
All right,
but I'll tell you right now,
I'm a little disappointed in a lot of you.
You're better than that.
Okay?
First of all,
if you live in a first world,
you should never tell somebody that's a first world fucking problem.
As if to remove yourself from your spoiled existence.
You know,
like you don't have some roast beef from the fridge that you didn't have to go
out and kill and maybe lose your oldest son trying to bring that fucking yak
down,
right?
Is that what rose piece come from?
Where does the roast beef come from?
That's some sort of steer,
I guess that's a steer cow.
You get the milk right?
Unless it fucking beats up other cows and then they fucking kill it and they
make steaks stares.
You get the steaks,
rump roasts and all that shit.
And then balls,
balls go around and they fuck the cows to make more stairs and more cows.
And my right.
Anybody,
anybody out there?
Farmer,
anybody out there in the fucking cattle game,
the cattle game,
that's,
that's a new movie or working on the cattle gain.
It's about a cow that has a dick and,
and it surprises and unsuspecting bull cause it's already fell in love with
them.
I just spoiled the secret of the cattle game.
Everybody.
Um,
this is the weirdest fucking podcast ever.
All right,
let's do a little bit of advertising here of you buddy.
so I can keep the podcast freek for all you fucking wine and cuts out there.
Um,
I know what to pay for the podcast.
This too much advertising.
Pick a fucking side.
Mary.
Uh,
legal zoom.
Everybody.
Uh,
I,
oops,
that's not it.
That was like a commentary on the fucking thing.
What the hell is it?
All right,
fuck it.
Let's call an audible,
like I just came up to the line,
you know,
I have to call in a play and I see it defense and I'm given a look to my fucking
receiver.
Right?
All I got those,
give them a look.
Marvin Harrison out there.
Did you kill anybody last night?
Who did you kill last night?
Wide Receiver.
A Tivo.
Everybody,
uh,
before Tivo watching TV was weirdly hard.
Weirdly hard.
I don't think it was,
I think it was pretty basic.
You know,
you turned it on,
you sat down,
you looked at it.
I've got issues with that,
but you know what,
I'm going to be a company man and I'm going to play ball here.
Bill burr reads the Tivo ad take to me.
Me,
me,
me.
Tivo.
Um,
before Tivo watching TV was weirdly hard.
You could only watch a show at a certain time and if you missed it or even a
part of it,
you literally had to wait for it to go into reruns before he could see it again.
Now I'm old enough to tell you that that's 100% true.
You missed one episode of happy days.
You didn't know what was going on.
How'd it Chachi knock up Joni?
When did they have a kid?
While you miss last week's episode,
have fun.
Wait until July.
Thank God that's all over.
Cause Tivo totally changed all of that.
And while our other dvrs exist,
they're not as sick malicious as Tivo.
Oh they're trying to get the young market here because if you have cable,
Tivo lets you watch your shows.
Wherever you want with Tivo stream,
you can watch on your iPad all over your house.
That's awesome man.
I actually have a little mini iPad enough.
I got to get this instead of just talking about it.
I should take action and even transfer your favorite recordings and take them
with you on an airplane waiting in line at the DMV dentist's office.
Tivo makes other dvrs looked like they were designed by some Soviet committee.
Ah,
take that one.
People over there and partial Europe and Asia.
Only Tivo searches for both cable and web to find any movie,
any show,
any video at the press of a button,
Netflix,
Amazon,
Youtube.
Now those are just doing so well,
wasn't I.
Now those are just like more channels on your TV and with the Tivo.
Mini one Tivo box works on a second TV from the couch to the kitchen from the
minivan to 35,000 feet.
Tivo.
Tivo makes TV about a thousand times better.
I don't know about you guys,
but I'm sold.
That's another great way to make a flight.
Go buy a watch every episode of welcome back.
Kotter one after another.
Boop Bap,
Bap d Bato Barda but doop bop a date by up do well in voice.
Everybody is screening calls,
closing deals and making money all while lounging poolside in the summer sun.
Thanks to who?
Ho a voice.
Everybody.
He voices a better way to connect with the people that drive your business.
He voice will forward your business calls to your home,
mobile or any number you choose.
Wherever you are.
Eva [inaudible].
We'll find you don't have time to take a call.
No problem.
It's routed to your voicemail and you can read it at your convenience as a text
message.
He voice not only gives you an edge over your competitors,
it takes away the edge of the big companies have over you right now with he
voice.
You can create the appearance of a whole office building of departments.
When customers call you a sales department,
customer support,
tech support,
you name it,
and it works with any phone,
even yourself.
Hey,
it's summer.
Don't be stuck in your office all day.
What's wrong with you?
Go out there and getting the sun.
Look at the ladies,
right?
Or if you're a woman,
go look at the fellas and there Harry pecs.
You know,
free yourself with a free 30 day trial of he voice.
You can see what I'm talking about or at least what I'm reading about.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter Promo code bill for 30 days for,
for up,
sorry for 30 day free tart trial.
Jesus.
You know,
I always like run down.
Great.
I get to the Horse,
I do my little flips and I never stick the landing.
Uh,
that's [inaudible] dot com promo code pill or go to the podcast page on
billboard.com and click on the voice banner.
And lastly,
dollar Shave Club.
Everybody.
How long have you been getting EFT in the a when it comes to buying blades for
your razor,
right?
Why are they acting like the little gold bullions?
They're not the little poor excuses for metal,
plastic hunks of crap and they lock them behind the register as if you're buying
some,
I dunno,
top shelf booze,
dollar shave club.
Everybody has made me so much happier about shaving.
You know why I don't have deal with anymore.
It's a great brand and they send you these quality razors right to your door
every month.
Okay.
So not only did I get them cheaper,
I don't have to stand behind some blue hair.
He was trying to figure out how to use their dose bag that she bought in the
1930s.
Okay.
You don't have to think about it.
You don't have to wait in line.
Get someone unlocked them from a cage and pay way too much money for a bunch of
features that don't even fit on your old handle.
Shaving is become a mess.
All right.
Eliminate all of that from your life.
The Dollar Shave Club.
You know what it does is saves me time.
It saves me money,
and the raises are great.
I've used them.
I dragged him right across my red face and I was smooth as a baby's bottom,
but not in a perverted way.
I want you to try it.
Do me a favor.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash burr support this show.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash [inaudible] or click on the dollar
shave club banner@thepodcastpagebillbird.com one more time in case you are,
you're on drugs.
That's dollar shave club.com forward slash birth Jesus Christ.
How many times I got to tell you,
Jesus Christ.
All right,
back to the podcast.
Here's something you don't get a lot on the podcast.
Everybody.
An apology I owe.
Two major apologies.
Three Jesus Christ.
Where do I start?
Number one,
I trashed World War z before it came out.
The second I saw the rating was PG 13 if you remember from a couple of weeks
back,
I said basically that the end of the world is not PG 13 it's like NC 17 if not
18 if that's,
if that's actually a rating.
Okay.
But I actually went out and I saw World War z and I gotta tell you something.
I absolutely loved it.
Not only did I love it,
I feel the PG 13 rating helped it.
You know,
cause we go on and see my act.
My act is probably NC 17 or at least rated r.
And if you really watched me,
I don't know how to write a joke.
That's why I have to scream and jump around and say the f word,
every other word.
And people still laugh because they don't realize I'm just doing a big parlor
trick.
That's all it is.
But the great thing is,
is when you go down to PG 13 they actually have to make a movie.
I'm PSN right now,
a bullshit.
And everybody,
I kept it PG 13 there,
you know,
you want to like,
they actually,
they build suspense.
And actually back in the day,
even in rated r movies,
they started building since they used to build suspense,
suspense.
And one of my things that I always hated about a horror movies and big time
blockbusters is once all they had all that CGI equipment,
you know,
they could have the perfect storm wave and all that crap.
They,
there was no story.
It's just a bunch of people and you just sitting there waiting for the big wave
to knock over the boat.
And uh,
one night I watched this movie,
dark night of the scarecrow and the movie,
I dunno,
there was really scared the shit out of me late at night.
And um,
I was trying to figure out why there was really nothing.
I couldn't figure out what it was.
They were building suspense.
They was scaring the shit out of me in world warZ didn't.
Brad Pitt was awesome.
So my apologies to Bradley Pitt Pride of Missouri in anybody else connected with
the World War z was a fucking great movie.
I highly recommended.
That's apology number one.
Paul g number two,
speaking of movies for the last two months,
I've been hyping the Billy red state tour,
talking about how all you guys drive,
you know,
a lot of people drive long distances to come and see me and I said,
you know what,
I'm going to come and see you.
But unfortunately,
actually,
fortunately I ended up getting some acting work and uh,
I can't control when they shoot stuff and it's really a big thing for me and uh,
I couldn't say no to it.
So unfortunately the Billy red state tour got kind of got split up.
Um,
I've rescheduled all of them.
All right.
I'm not going to totally sell out and just say,
well,
I got act and work.
I'm not doing these.
I just rescheduled them.
So this is the deal.
Um,
the first two dates,
Boise,
Idaho in Boseman,
Montana,
those ones are still the same dates.
Everything else got moved.
Um,
as of right now,
the only rescheduled dates I can give you is boulder.
Colorado is September 4th and pikes peak Colorado is September 6th and I believe
we're looking at Oklahoma and uh,
Kansas deck deck up moved to like November.
This is the deal.
I'm still coming to all of those places.
Just not in the next two weeks.
I apologize.
I know it's the summer you probably said,
hey,
I can't go water skiing and bang that chick.
I always wanted to bang back in high school but didn't have the balls.
And now I said the right shit.
You know,
I hope I didn't fuck up something like that for you.
All right.
But if you're just going to play frisbee with some cow chips than I think he can
wait a couple of months.
Is that really the apology started off as one.
Um,
and then lastly,
the last apology that I have
is uh,
I have to apologize to jollied all jolly old England.
I usually watch Wimbledon every year,
but I've been so busy I missed out and I ended up the one fucking year.
I don't watch it.
Um,
the first English champions since I don't know when I'm going to guess the 1930s
again,
Andy Murray,
congratulations for being the first a human being with Dick and balls from Great
Britain.
Or should I say England,
which is Great Britain.
Let's see the United Kingdom,
who gives a fuck about geography,
whatever.
He's from England.
I wish I could've seen,
I mean I've even watched a clip of it to see how fucking crazy everybody went.
So my apologies.
I should've given you guys your props.
Uh,
that's awesome.
I'm sure you guys are still fucking celebrating.
I think that's a great thing.
Great for the sport and uh,
and to sports.
Yet another person from overseas sent me another video about rugby.
You know,
one of those clips where they show all these unbelievably hard hits and they are
hard hits,
you know,
but they always had kind of have to come at me like saying an American football
is for pussies cause they were all this equipment.
So here's what I have to say to rugby people,
fans of rugby,
who think that American football players are somehow pussies slash not as tough
as rugby.
Uh,
rugby players put it this way,
when rugby players like two,
three years after they retire,
start committing suicide by shooting themselves in the chest because they don't
want to damage their brain.
So scientists can look at it after they're dead to figure out why this is so
fucked up.
You know,
when rugby players start doing that,
okay,
then,
um,
then maybe you haven't,
even then you wouldn't have an argument,
then your sport would be as fucked up as ours,
you know?
And if you want to win that contest,
you know,
our support does more damage to our citizens than your stores,
then,
you know,
more power to you.
But I'm just saying,
I don't think rugby guys,
they don't kill themselves,
do they?
I have no fucking idea.
I didn't run,
I didn't really research it one way or the other.
Um,
all right.
So I know a lot of people,
you know,
I were asking me questions here.
Wanted me to comment on that.
Uh,
that case down there in Florida.
I gotta be honest with you.
Once it went,
it was so racial from the beginning.
That shit just,
uh,
depresses the hell out of me.
It makes me feel like there's never going to be any sort of progress.
I think that there's progress in uh,
you know,
maybe stuff in movies and stuff that people say on TV.
But I still think people have a lot of the same thoughts.
Unfortunately they do.
And a,
so I don't know anything about it.
All I can say is that I feel a lot of the people,
some of the Shit I had actually stopped like following like three people on
Twitter cause the shit they were writing was so fucking ignorant about it.
Um,
basically by ignorant,
I mean not talking about the case,
making it this whole fucking race thing and uh,
and people like that on both sides.
I would say that if it was flipped in,
the exact opposite thing happened,
you know,
played out the same way except it was a 17 year old white kid that killed,
got killed by an African American adult.
Those same people would completely flip on whether they thought it was guilt or
innocence.
And that's what fucking drives me nuts about the shit and depresses me.
Um,
but I mean,
Bryce was a big thing about it.
I can tell you this right now.
If an African American male adult shot a 17 year old white kid,
uh,
with who had skittles and ice tea,
okay.
I don't know.
I would not want to be the defendant in that fucking case.
Put it that way.
I wouldn't.
So another fucking unfortunate.
It just gets so,
you know,
do you really think,
I actually,
let me ask you this.
Do you think people are that ignorant or that they just show the ignorant
people?
Okay.
You know,
I don't fucking know,
but I get overwhelming.
You depressed when I wash it like that,
so I kind of stayed away from it.
Um,
so anyways,
I don't know why I brought that up.
It's just a,
it's a fucking awful topic.
I do have to say though,
for the little,
I know about the stand your ground law,
I don't understand why that exists.
MMM.
Most other states,
you have to have exhausted any option of,
of retreat.
You know,
like every martial arts class you ever take,
like they always say the first fucking defense is to avoid it.
If you can avoid it in any way,
regardless of what,
hey you fucking pussy your mother's occurred or whatever.
That's just words you supposed to just walk away from something like that.
You know,
in the old and it's just when you get to the point where your back's against the
wall,
you know you got to defend yourself,
which I 100% belief,
but that stand your ground
where your wife's going.
Like,
honey,
they're kind of angry.
Let's the drunk.
I think we should just,
I ain't [inaudible] staying in my fucking Brown.
That just,
that just sounds,
that sounds aggressive.
Like,
I don't know.
The stand your ground law and I'm just asking here before you start sending me
emails written all in capital letters.
All right.
To me that just sounds like
you're escalating.
That's a way to escalate a situation,
you know?
Do you know what people fucking stood their ground and just wish that they
didn't,
or in wheelchairs now,
or missing eyes or fucking drool all day long is standing your ground is one of
the dumbest fucking things you can do with a complete stranger who gives a fuck.
They're not in your life,
you know?
Oh,
is that what you think about me?
Person who doesn't know me and I'll never see again.
That's good.
Okay,
you're right.
I'm walking away.
I Dunno,
I don't know much about the law,
but you have reminds me a long time ago when I watched this bouncer,
he walked up,
there was two people arguing and he comes walking up.
Now his job is to fucking,
you know,
and the situation diffuse it,
right?
Hopefully by just talking,
you know,
so he comes walking up and he says,
Hey,
what's the problem here?
And the guy talking to him goes with this guy here,
blah,
blah.
And He,
and he,
he,
he put his hand on the bounce,
his like more like,
Hey,
I want to talk to you to tell you what happened.
And the bouncer immediately goes,
first of all,
don't touch me and I,
I can't do it the way he delivered the line,
but I immediately started fucking die and laughing.
Okay.
Because what he then did,
he just escalated the situation and then that guy who was mad at the other guy
took the anger he already had and then focus it on the bouncer and then
immediately they're both on the ground rolling around on the floor.
And it was just like,
oh.
What struck me as so funny was that that bouncer came over there and it was just
like,
did you want to fight the guy?
Why would you say that?
Okay.
It should just said,
sir,
I just need you to keep your hands down there.
Thank you.
Now we know what,
what,
what are you saying?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
Go that word.
But it would be like,
first of all,
don't touch making fucking like slap his hand away or whatever.
I Dunno,
I dunno about that.
Stand your ground.
Thanks.
So I'm also very ignorant of as you can tell.
So,
uh,
let me know.
I'm going to wait to,
everything dies down,
then I'm going to try to read up on the fucking case.
But I,
I can't watch it when it's like rolling stone is so frigging to the left and
then you watch Fox News and yeah.
You know,
you know how they are over there.
Like it's,
it's so hard to try and get some sort of like sanity and all of that and uh,
uh,
you combine that with every fucking jerk off,
whereas an opinion can write something on the Internet.
I just kind of avoided the whole fucking thing.
Um,
okay.
Who knows?
Alright,
there you go.
So you asked,
I said I hope I didn't fucking piss anybody off and make it any more painful.
Um,
all right.
And with that,
hey,
you know something,
somebody wrote something,
some fucked up drink to me that they had that I was in and a actually wrote
something funny back.
I like to think funny back to,
uh,
analyzing his dream just to give you something else to talk and keep the podcast
fresh.
If you guys want me to,
if you had a fucked up dream over the next like six days and maybe one you had a
few weeks ago and it's bugging you and you want me to interpret your dreams.
Alright.
Belper red carpets,
your drapes,
straight straight drains.
Drains will be a new segment hopefully
next week on the podcast.
And they don't,
obviously,
you don't have to be about me.
I hope I didn't confuse anybody there.
All right,
this is gonna be some fucking,
you know,
narcissistic thing.
Even though I am sitting here by myself,
I'm too fucking arrogant to have a guest or lazy or whatever you want to call.
If you want to fucking frame it,
that's up to you.
I don't tell you how to think,
so why,
yeah.
If you have a weird fucking dream,
uh,
send it in and I'll,
I'll interpret your drape.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
I want to thank everybody who came out this week.
I was in my old stomping grounds.
Uh,
went to the Cape Cod melody tent,
which was a,
uh,
just an absolute,
that was a dream come true to be able to perform in that place.
That's the one and only place I ever saw George Carlin.
And uh,
it was amazing.
I couldn't believe how small it was.
Anytime you're in the round like that many seats looks small because you're like
cutting the ring off.
It's Kinda like how Dane Cook did it when he would,
would do like those giant arenas.
It's fucking brilliant.
Cause if we do one like a giant place like that and you put the stage on one
side,
it's like that person in the last row up top is a zillion miles away.
But if you put it in the middle,
it's like if I,
you guys do,
you can do the fucking math.
You don't have to be in construction.
You know what I mean?
I'm 50% closer to you and that last row is 50% closer.
The second to last row,
everything is 50% closer.
Isn't except for like the front row,
but isn't,
isn't there more front row with the circle?
Not Jesus,
I'm all confused.
I'm starting to sweat here.
Um,
so anyways,
went down there,
I just had a,
I had a fucking great time and um,
I was having such a good time,
I forgot to promote that I was selling my DVDs afterwards.
So I apologize to anybody who wanted a picture of something like that.
I did come out afterwards,
uh,
there was like 30,
35 people there.
Needless to say,
I left a lot of fucking DVDs in a box back in Massachusetts.
Um,
and then the next night I did the Hampton Beach Ball Room Casino,
uh,
which is one of my favorite fucking gigs.
Um,
I was up there,
was working with Paul Versey and then a buddy of mine,
Wayne Previti,
uh,
who I started off doing stand up with a long time ago back in Boston.
And we all hung out and had a great time.
And then the final night was the Newport yachting festival,
yachting centers,
sorry,
which was a,
you know,
an,
an air condition tent in a parking lot.
And it was,
I don't know if it was global warming or what,
but it was the hottest it's ever been.
I don't know if anybody took any pictures of me when I was on stage,
but I was wearing this button down shirt that was really thin and I thought it
was going to be cool,
but all it did,
it was like you ever workout wearing a great t shirt?
How fucking disgusting you look afterwards.
That's what I look like.
Um,
it was gross,
but I hung in there and actually I got like 50 minutes in and then I just felt
like I was,
I got like almost like runner's high.
I was so fucking hot and I ended,
I think I did like an hour and a half.
It was one of the longest I've ever done on stage.
Standing up there and a,
I just had a great time and consume nine zillion calories as I always do.
I took Versie on a fucking,
uh,
we should have filmed it on this foodie tour of all this shit that I used to be
able to eat in my early twenties and wake up the next day and still have a flat
stomach.
Dare I say abs.
I took it like what's great about Massachusetts,
if you ever go out there is like every two to three towns has just some
unbelievable fucking place to get pizza.
And there it's,
I think they call it bar bar pizza where it's basically the size of a small and
a,
okay.
I'm telling you the place I have,
which I'm not even going to tell you what it is cause I don't want to blow it up
because I want to fucking be able to come back there and get a seat.
Um,
when I did the movie the heat,
um,
Nate Cordrey told me about a place he knew down off of route three.
Okay.
That was fucking unbelievable.
And um,
I don't know.
Maybe if you guys want to have the guys want to out some of your spots,
it's a great thing to do.
And then I took him to this fucking ice cream place afterwards.
It's like we were on a date,
he took them to this ice cream place that's right on a farm.
All right.
And you get a small,
okay,
you get a small fucking dish of ice cream,
right?
And they put the sprinkles on the bottom,
by the way,
in Massachusetts that called Jimmy's.
And I just found out that that's what I heard.
That's actually racist because I guess like that was another term for African
Americans back in the day,
like Jim crow laws.
So Hey,
there's a couple of Jimmy's over their kid or whatever.
So they call it,
because the sprinkles lot of times with chocolate called them jimmies.
Right.
So I probably shouldn't even fucking said that.
Cause now racist will be like,
oh good,
a new way to be a cunt.
But anyways,
so I always say sprinkles when I'm up,
even though that,
that always makes me feel like silly,
saying that like,
could I get some sprinkles?
I'll just a little flustered.
Um,
now was that homophobic?
I Made Jesus.
It's just a bear trap wherever you step.
So whatever.
They put the fucking sprinkles on the bottom.
And the small is basically like eating a pint of fucking ice cream so that we
walk over,
we sit on a bench,
me and Paul Versey sitting on a bench in defense of us,
it was made for three.
All right.
We're sitting there eating ice cream,
looking at the cows from the farm where I get they get the fucking cream and the
milk or whatever the fuck they get.
A,
what is the cream come out of the cow?
Is that somewhere around between the tank and the,
uh,
the other there?
Is that what it is?
Does it got an extra valve?
You know what I mean?
Like that one that's just for hot water.
I don't fucking know.
So we're sitting there and I said,
I shouldn't even tell you this,
not,
I can't tell you this.
I said,
I'm gonna to take a picture of us and I'm going to send this to Nia and she's
going to fucking trash us.
And that's exactly,
I bet them a dollar.
And of course she did.
Um,
and then,
so whatever,
we went up to Hampton beach that night and we,
we do the Gig.
Um,
this is a place like Aero Smith when I first started out,
rumors has it,
that led Zepplin actually played there.
If they did,
it's probably one of maybe,
uh,
I know they played the,
the Boston tea party.
I know they played the whiskey out here in la.
They play,
they literally played like I think a dozen small venues before they absolutely
blew up and just went to,
I imagine large theaters and obviously arenas.
But uh,
last time I was there they were claiming that,
that,
that might have been one of the places that they played.
Um,
and also long time ago,
I remember I was in a bad relationship and I walked up the boardwalk and I was
like,
I want to get out of this relationship.
I want to turn my life around.
And I saw George Carlin's name outside of there and I remember thinking,
that's what I want to be doing.
I want to be doing,
stand up not being in this fucked up relationship.
Right.
So we had a great time and then I'm racing back to get some Chinese food at this
place to,
to to I will out displace the,
the uh,
the Tahiti and a dead mass and I'm telling you right now you can't fuck with the
Chinese food and Massachusetts.
Oh hour,
however far it goes,
where they have a poo poo platter.
They have chicken fingers there.
Pork spare ribs,
they're crab.
Rangoon I'm telling you,
New York,
you don't even know what the fuck good Chinese food is.
New York had the worst Chinese food that the dirty,
his God damn fucking restaurants I've ever been to the Chinese food,
every fucking you walk in,
first of all they'd be like bulletproof glass.
It was all scraped up and dirty and smudged and then there was this filthy
fucking bicycle.
They never mopped the floor.
They were the dirtiest fucking place of everybody to in my life.
You go to fucking the ones up here in Massachusetts or when I was out there in
Massachusetts,
dude,
it was like a fucking lounge.
Get a score.
People don't write fucking 12 drunks with 12 straws sucking down like five
different alcohols with Hawaiian Punch in there.
These big lounges,
these fucking looking like a look at that.
That shit on the Brady bunch where they lost the Tki.
Everybody,
everybody fucking dawn hall walking by with a Ukulele,
which I know is Hawaiian.
I don't give a fuck.
It was great insane food.
So I did this thing with the,
uh,
I hate when I have an early flight and I have to get,
I have to fill up the tank with gas because I always end up almost missing my
flight.
Um,
so finally I chose the full tank of gas option,
which sucks because then you got to drive around on ie cause you don't want to
get fucked because if he come back with a half a tank that still charging you
for a full tank and the fuck over extra price,
you know,
for a gallon of gas.
So I'm driving back from New Hampshire and,
uh,
the fucking light is blinking that we're going to run out of gas and we already
ordered food.
And versus sitting there,
gone not to,
we're going to make it,
we're gonna make it.
And we pulled in,
we made it,
we got the food,
everything was great.
And I came out to start up the fucking SUV,
little poor excuse for an SUV and it did the start.
That's how low on gas I was.
It was on fumes.
And fortunately I read up a little bit on,
uh,
cars and I was thinking of water.
If I pump it a little bit and then maybe I can get a few drops out of the fuel
line and get across the street and it happened,
started the fucker up,
you know,
cause my dumb ass,
that's how little I knew about cars.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't have stepped on the gas more.
I would've
okay
that w I just would assume there was nothing left.
Um,
and then we ate it and then the next day my stomach was 10 times fucking bigger.
But you know what?
I stand by it.
I had a great time.
Listen to Paul versus a podcast.
I guarantee you the verse,
the effect,
he brings it up this week.
Um,
all right,
let's get back to the,
let's do a little advertising here,
a little freak,
little frack here.
A stamps.com everybody,
I've already told you how not to have to ever go and have to buy a,
what do you call blades for your razor anymore.
So already right there.
That's one less trip you have to make out of the house.
Where his his one less trip number two.
So that would be two less trips unless you decided to go run errands.
Doing both at the same time.
I don't know how you live your life.
All right.
stamps.com everybody with this summer in full swing.
There are a lot of places we want to go,
but the post office isn't one of the driving their parking waiting for a clerk.
What a hassle,
man.
Why don't you just use stamps.com instead stamps.com anything else?
Anything you would do with the post office,
you can do right from your desk by and print official US postage for any
envelope,
any package,
any class of male.
Just use what you already have,
your own computer and printer stamps.com we'll make it easy and convenient.
It's like having a postal expert available 24 seven whenever you need it.
You'll never have to go to the post office again.
I'm going to say that again,
people.
You'll never have to go to the post office again unless you're some Weirdo that
collects stamps.
I use stamps on stamps.com to send out all my DVDs.
I've never had a problem and I'm a moron right now.
Use a my last name bur bur for this special offer,
no risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer offer includes a digital scale and up to
$55 free posts,
postage.
So it was the last third.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the page,
uh,
and type in bird that stamps.com and enter birth.
All right.
Legal Zoom.
Most most Americans don't have a will,
but why?
Well,
I guess a lot of us don't own enough stuff.
You know
what a depressing way to start it.
Let's start this one over.
Everybody.
Legal Zoom.
Most Americans don't have a will,
but why?
You don't want government rules dictating what happens to your property and
minor children.
Do you,
so why procrastinate?
Most people say it's too expensive,
too time consuming.
Too much of a pain in the age.
My answer to all your problems as legal zoom.com too expensive.
You're going to love legal zooms,
reasonable prices,
too.
Time consuming.
Uh,
most people finish the online process and just 20 minutes,
20 minutes to protect your assets and your family after you're gone.
Uh,
and we're not talking some fill in the blank form you.
Your will is state specific and personalized.
It's personalized based on your information.
Best of all,
legal zoom has 12 years of experience helping people with important legal
matters.
Um,
it's national make a will month everyone.
So don't wait any longer from the people who want to make money off making
wills.
Everybody.
It's national.
Make a will month.
Go to legalzoom.com today and get 50% off your last will,
but this offer ends soon or a living trust and you'll receive a pour over will
absolutely free.
Um,
that's it.
People,
you should do it.
You know what?
I should do it.
I haven't even done it yet.
Nia has been on me.
You know what?
I'm going to go to legal zoom just like,
Yo,
let's have a race who can get their will done first.
Uh,
to get your special discount,
be sure to enter Burr in the referral box at checkout for wills,
powers of attorneys,
trust and more.
Go to legal zoom.com legal zoom can provide self help services at yours purse
specific direction or connect with an attorney,
but they are not a law firm.
All right.
There you are.
Let's go back to the podcast.
Everybody.
You know what?
I've been running my yap talking about myself long enough.
I have an idea.
I have an idea as they say.
Why don't we read a couple of letters?
Bulgaria,
Bulgaria be buddy that's an eastern Europe,
just south of the Ukraine capital is uh,
don't tell me.
Yeah.
Ah,
Shit.
I had this one
is that Sophia was at Belarus.
Look at that.
I didn't Polish up on them for one fucking week.
No,
it's Sophia,
right?
Then what the Hell is Belarus?
Okay.
A Chrysler can't even fucking remember anymore.
What an asshole.
Yeah,
it is Sophia.
But what's Belarus now I'm looking it up.
Doodoo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo.
Zip Is Ipap Papa.
Oh,
I can't sing that song or else the ghost of a big headed mo there.
He gets the money.
I pat say Jack.
What the fuck's his name?
Okay.
Yeah,
it gives a fuck.
All right.
Bulgaria urge.
You mentioned Bulgaria in the last podcast.
The hairs around my asshole rose up and excitement that you would visit.
I checked your schedule and there are only two euro cities listed.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You cunt.
Um,
despite your tone,
despite our insulting,
you just were,
I feel as though that.
Um,
okay.
You really don't feel I'm that I just feel you're disappointed.
All right,
so I'm going to plow through all your anger that you just sent me and I have to
ask you this.
Bulgaria is one of those those countries I don't know anything about,
and as an American,
if you don't know anything about the country,
you have to assume that it's a dangerous place for Americans to go.
Part of that is ignorance.
The other part is our foreign policy.
We've pissed off a lot of people,
so I have to ask you this.
You seem to have command,
okay,
I'll be it in an angry way of the English language.
Could I actually go to Bulgaria and a fight?
Do what is what is there to do there?
Is it war toward,
have you made a comeback?
Let me,
let me hear about Bulgaria and in general,
let me hear about Eastern Europe.
What's go,
what's going on over there at Bosnia and Herzegovina?
Okay.
Slovenia,
Slovakia,
Hudson Pfeffer,
cooperative.
But we're going to do with just a couple of eastern Europe car making be even
fucking Milwaukee.
We're gonna Shave our mustaches for you.
Potato dilemma.
Hey Billy,
red face.
I find myself at a big career decision point in my life and I'm not completely
sure what to do.
I'm a 22 year old guy and I studied languages at a university here in Finland.
Oh,
hall of Nokia.
Um,
on many summers I've worked for a potato packaging company that is owned by my
father's side of the family.
That's fucking awesome.
See that right there.
You know why that,
that,
that guy and his family are secure is that is about as tangible as it gets.
Potatoes,
you can hold them in your hands.
You stick them in a package,
right.
Just like the old days.
Uh,
recently my cousin who works there,
uh,
regularly at work there regularly asked me whether I'd be interested in joining
him and taking over the company as the old low owners.
My uncles and my dad are retiring soon.
I never had much of a relationship with my dad,
but he's still likely be happy to have one of his children take over now.
I don't really know if I should accept the offer.
I would likely secure it would likely secure me a pretty good living in my adult
life.
But the thought of being able to see my future laid down before me,
like that is a bit scary.
So far I've never really planned ahead and honestly I ended up in the university
studying English just because I didn't know what else to do.
Well,
you know what?
As far as I know about a Finland over there,
don't you guys pay like 90% tax?
But everything's taken care of.
You know,
health insurance,
college tuition is,
is all paid.
Hence don't you guys have a problem over there with people like you,
young people who don't know what they want to do,
everything's taken care of.
Why go out in the real world and have 90% of your check go out the window for
shit that you're not going to be using unless you get a fucking hemorrhoid.
Right?
They kind of created the terminal college student.
Um,
I'm just asking anyways,
this has led to some lack of motivations and my studies as I don't really know
where I'm going going with it at all.
Um,
I just haven't had a plant,
by the way.
How great is this guy's English better than me?
I just haven't had a plan and I've always felt like a bit of an underachiever in
my family.
He knows the word underachiever.
I know some French words.
I don't know what underachievers under achiever.
It's a five syllable fucking word.
I barely use that in my own language.
I applaud you sir.
I'm with all my oldest siblings having gone to successful careers in education
and medicine from their university studies where I've just been drifting along
with no destination so far.
Uh,
as a regular employee,
the work and the potato company has never been terribly exciting.
But as the owner,
I'd obviously have more control and what kinds of things I could do.
There's also the possibility that I could refocus my studies into something more
business oriented,
uh,
maybe taking over the marketing side of things in the future.
Should I accept this offer or should I wait until I found a career path I feel
more certain about,
I just don't know if I'm ever going to find it.
Obviously I'm lucky to even be in this situation.
Uh,
but it's just a bit overwhelming to have such a big decisions,
uh,
to make it this age,
which I haven't really thought about seriously before.
Thanks.
Have a good day and go fuck yourself.
Um,
doe this,
this decision's all going to be in your gut.
You're going to have to go with your gut,
dude.
I can't,
I can't make the decision what you should do with your life.
Um,
I do feel that you should have a passion if you want to have fun at work,
uh,
for what you do and um,
you know,
but if you just kind of floating around aimlessly,
huff and out of a bong,
maybe this could,
could be a good thing for you.
I'm just playing devil's advocate.
I don't know what you're doing.
All right.
And I also imagined that,
you know,
if you take this and you don't like it,
you could always sell your stake in it to the other person,
your cousin or whatever that you're going to go into business with.
So it does give you an asset,
which is something that a lot of young people don't have.
Um,
gives you a little bit of footing.
I don't think it's the worst thing.
I mean,
I don't think potatoes are going out of style.
Are they?
People always gonna need potatoes.
Um,
I dunno,
but at the end of the day,
dude,
you're going to have to make,
you're not going to have to make that decision.
Um,
personally I would not want to be in the potato business,
but I would love to grow some in my own yard.
By the way.
Everybody I told you about how we planted some cucumbers and tomatoes and
peppers,
I can't recommend it enough when they finally are ripe and you bring them in,
it's like fucking magic.
And I live in a climate out here where I can grow them all year round.
I haven't had the tomatoes yet,
but Nia picked one and sent me a video.
She bit into it like an apple.
And um,
I don't know if you guys know a lot of,
you know,
with the tomatoes,
a lot of just vegetables in general.
They pick them before they're ripe and they let them ripen on the truck.
But basically the second you pull it off vine,
you know,
it's not getting any more nutrients.
And that's why a lot of like,
especially tomatoes just suck at least in this country,
which is why when you order a Capri Salad,
you know,
they have to put that Balsamic vinegarette on it to give it a little bit of a
fucking,
uh,
the Balsamic,
whatever the fuck they put on it,
to give it a little zip to make up for the sugar that's not in the,
in the tomatoes,
that sweet tastes that's not there.
At the same thing when you make your pizza sauces,
you've got to throw some sugar in there because tomatoes over here suck.
But if you grow your own,
um,
you don't have to worry about that.
The only thing you have to worry about is no one went to fucking take them off,
which I fucked up with the cucumbers.
I took them off too soon.
MMM.
But it's the greatest thing ever.
So getting back to the,
uh,
the,
what you're doing here,
sir.
And by the way,
I'm going to have a whole fucking garden,
you know,
and then I figure what I'm going to use for protein is,
uh,
the rabbits that I killed that try and steal my vegetables.
I'm going to be eating a lot of varmints,
a lot of fucking,
uh,
some rabbit stew,
some possum soup,
you know,
fucking Raccoon Burger,
side of rabies.
Um,
yeah,
dude,
I w you're 22 years old.
I mean,
I don't at 22.
I really don't think you should know what the fuck you want to do with your
life.
MMM.
Buying it on a business and some fucking old man shit.
You should at least own one pair of suspenders before you make a decision like
that,
I would think.
MMM.
But I get what you're saying like this,
this,
this window of opportunity might not be open when you're 23,
and then what if you fucking don't find something else?
Uh,
you know something,
dude,
by the time I was 22,
I knew I wanted to be a comedian.
So at 22 if you don't,
they feel you want to be a potato farmer,
then that's probably a pretty good indication,
you know?
Although you also have to take into effect that,
uh,
are taking it to our fucking hour,
the expression goes,
you got to factor in the fact that I'm super imposing when I figured out what
the fuck I wanted to do onto your life,
okay?
Some people don't figure out to they're 40.
So I would go with my gut all right?
And have faith in yourself as a human being that yet,
you know,
your life is your life and you're on your journey.
Okay?
And when you meet the person you're supposed to be with,
or you,
you meet,
you find the career,
you're supposed to be
the job you're supposed to be doing in life,
you're going to feel it.
I'm telling you,
when you find that in life that you never questioned it.
You know?
And this is feeling of relief and excitement,
you know?
So unless you look at a field of potatoes growing and it gives you a lump in
your throat because it's so goddamn beautiful to you.
I don't think you want to do it.
That's what my gut says.
All right.
Well like said,
that's a huge decision decision.
You gotta make it for yourself.
Okay.
I hope that helped.
And uh,
go fuck yourself right back at you.
And I'll be over there in December.
You know what the London dates selling really well.
I know I don't have a mall up there,
but I don't post dates until this ticket links because then I got to deal with
people going like,
well,
well why in the fuck are texts go on sale?
I don't know.
All right.
Moving on.
Weight loss.
Everyone.
A belt.
Just wanting to say,
I'm representing you here in Maine on the last couple of the episodes you've
brought exercising and fatty.
Oh,
I guess brought up exercising and fatties you forgot the up and wanted to let
you know that you've given me an extra motivation to keep off the weight.
I've,
I've lost in nine months.
I've lost a hundred pounds on the mark.
Hang on a second.
Good for you,
sir.
Good for you.
That's 500 miles of capillaries.
Your heart doesn't have to pump through every fucking beat anymore.
I can't even remember.
That's even right.
Every pound of fat is five miles of capillaries.
Huh?
You fucking kidding me?
That's why even an exit,
10 pounds extra 10 pounds,
you slowly killing yourself.
Hundred pounds,
dude,
congratulations.
He goes a 22 and a 225 pounds.
I've never looked or felt any better.
The question I wanted to ask you is,
what is your take on diets?
I just control my portion sizes and lay off junk food.
Also,
I try to drink at least 1.5 gallons of water a day.
Okay.
Ah,
dude,
you gotta be careful with that.
You can actually die from drinking too much water.
1.5 gallon.
You're a big guy though.
If you're fucking 225 pounds,
you still in shape.
Um,
I would look into that,
man.
Are you sure that's how much you're drinking?
Anybody listening to this?
And please do not go out and drink 1.5 gallons of water in a day.
You're not supposed to drink like eight glasses.
Okay.
And even I,
you gotta Watch out.
This is something we can literally drown yourself.
We'll use the cell walls.
Like,
I can't remember,
they did this radio contest.
Whoever could drink the most fucking water,
one an x box and some mother went in there to do it for a kid.
She ended up dying.
It's fucking horrific.
But anyways,
let's,
let's just go back to the sea goes.
Is that,
is that too much?
Um,
I would,
I would go to a doctor on this one buddy.
Okay.
Um,
he says,
nice putting out the podcast definitely keeps me focused on my car to go days.
Thanks.
Um,
do I believe in diets?
No,
I don't.
I think they just make you miserable.
I think it is portion control and you cut out bad foods.
You just have to get through those first three,
four days to seven days where you're,
you're not craving,
you're not on that salt,
sugar,
salt,
you know,
back and forth,
junky.
Most people,
even if they are in shape,
like are still fighting that battle,
like a,
not in the best of shape,
but I'm not in bad shape either,
but I fight that all the fucking time.
And I actually,
you know,
I got that ice cream with [inaudible] and the next day I was driving by it again
and I had the urge to go back and get some more fucking ice cream,
you know,
justifying it like,
well,
I'm not going to be here.
I don't know how many more months.
If I lived here,
I'd go here all the time.
But Bob on,
I said,
fuck that and uh,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I'm out here wishing I did get it the second time and um,
but I'm glad I didn't.
So,
um,
the fuck am I talking about?
Yeah,
I believe in a portion control dude is you just have like,
usually the shit they say of a protein the size of the palm of your hand and
he'd just have vegetables with no statues of cabs.
You do that like before seven o'clock at night,
just drink water the rest of the night no more just,
and then you go,
just go for a walk around the block before you go to bed and then don't eat
again for like 12 hours until you wake up.
It's seven again.
It just sucks the first couple of nights.
Then your body gets used to it,
so you won't be filling those hunger pangs.
And uh,
and then,
you know,
you just keep doing that.
You wake up,
you have fucking oatmeal.
There's nowhere for the fat to go.
It has to leave.
He's getting kicked out by good food.
That's what I would do.
And you know what,
I would do that I never really did.
I would read up on nutrition,
uh,
a great guy to actually follow on Facebook as Eddie Brill from the Dave
Letterman show,
standup comedian.
Um,
like I learned so much shit just by following him on Facebook.
Like he,
he's,
he's broken it down all the way down to the bottled water.
If that,
he'd rather drink out of the tap from some of the shit that he's reading about
bottled water.
It's amazing.
But,
um,
there's a bunch of stuff out there.
There's other things you can do like eat,
uh,
eat and seasoned,
um,
gold.
Go to farmer's markets and then actually know what's in season.
Like I'll tell you right now,
peaches are in season.
I've never been,
I never had peaches in my diet and I just started eating shit that was in
season.
Peaches and seasons are fucking unbelievable.
Like if you get a peach right now,
you got to eat it over the sink.
It's the smoke,
the most insane thing ever.
And one of the greatest things you could ever eat after,
uh,
after cardio,
you know,
I don't know.
So wait,
what am I fucking,
who's that guy with the candy striped shorts,
you know,
with the tank tops and the fucking balding Afro.
What the Hell's his name?
Richard Simmons.
Oh,
Bill Simmons here.
Bill Sevens.
I supposed to be doing this podcast.
I worked for fucking trying to work out a date,
uh,
where I can come in and do his podcast.
All right?
A fat person is saying thank you.
Look at me.
I'm,
I'm a,
I'm inspiring the fat east.
Um,
dare bill Baer,
Billy Aaron Burr.
I've been fat or obese most of my life and I want to thank you for shaming me
into losing weight and getting into shape is,
see that shame works.
Most people might get offended when you talk about fatties and gluttonous
people,
but I took your criticism and jokes to heart and went from 430 to 220.
Wait a minute,
look at this.
He did it a little under 18 months and he goes,
I'm not done yet.
I'm almost 40 years old.
And my goal now is to get to 180 pounds,
which I haven't been since I was in the seventh grade,
but I will settle for a little less than 200 pounds.
Do,
do you understand that you basically just saved your fucking life.
You're 40 years old and you're 430 pounds.
You're not long for this earth.
Okay.
And the greatest example,
when was the last time you saw a 430 pounds?
70 year old.
How about a 60 year old?
How about a 50 year old?
Have you seen even like a 50 year old,
you know.
Okay.
He just,
you can't,
you can't do it.
He just can't fucking do it.
So good for your man.
And you know anybody else who's fat.
When I do these fat jokes,
I'm,
I'm rooting for you,
man.
I,
I try and make everything fine.
Make Fun of myself for going bald,
being a redheaded cunt.
All right.
Don't take it.
I want you to lose.
All right,
good for you,
dude.
That's insane.
That's what,
210 pounds.
He lost a cornerback.
That's unbelievable.
Uh,
I am almost 40 years old now and my goal all got,
I read that part.
He goes,
I feel like a new man board.
I most I'm most happy about is how much my dick is growing.
Wow.
All right.
This just took a fucking left turn.
He goes,
because of all of the blubber.
I Ha I had,
oh,
because all the blubber,
I had no idea,
but it looks like I had,
I have at least an eight inch cock and that makes me a lot more confident about
myself.
Well,
dude,
how long have you been fat?
You must have been fat before puberty cause you said you were,
you,
you were a 180 pounds in seventh grade.
Ah,
dude,
you were that kid right there.
Plain shirts and skins and you sitting there praying and praying to God,
they don't get you for skins.
Ah,
man,
that's fucking brutal.
Good for you.
Look at him after all these years.
He found his dick.
That's tremendous.
Um,
he goes,
I know it's going to be hard,
but uh,
I work out at least two hours each day and five days each week.
Thanks for being a jerk off.
Some people need tough love.
I owe it all to you.
Ah,
I don't know,
man.
I got you going,
but you fucking did it.
You work out five,
two hours each day,
five days a week.
Look at this comes full circle.
Now you're,
uh,
you're inspiring me.
Okay.
I was going to take today off cause I flew on a plane.
Be a big pussy who I flew across the country.
I can't go walk around the block.
Um,
good for you man.
That's fucking awesome.
All right.
Now,
now that you're actually going to live past 50,
do me a favor.
Speaking of 50 don't drive in the fucking left lane.
All right.
If you're making a left and the light turns green,
get out into the intersection.
So not only the guy behind you but the guy behind him.
We can all fucking make it.
All right.
Other than that,
go back to Eaton Sundays cause we can't use you.
I'm kidding.
Don't do it.
All right.
Hulu plus everybody you've tried streaming hit shows in your PC on hulu.com now
it's time to try to start your free trial of exclusive content in your living
room and on your mobile devices on Hulu plus.
That's right.
They've taken hulu.com and they've taken it to another level who with Hulu plus
you get total control to watch thousands of shows wherever you want,
whenever you want.
Use Hulu plus on connected TVs,
game sows gain console's gained souls.
So you know,
where is my brain?
I get too far ahead.
Game Consoles,
Blueray ray players,
Roku,
apple TV,
PC,
or watch from anywhere on your smartphone or tablet on demand at all times and
with Hulu plus you can binge on full seasons.
What's your favorite current shows?
And even watch a full series run of classic TV shows.
It's endless.
They've got community,
modern family,
southpark,
SNL,
Jimmy Kimmel,
family guy,
and much,
much more.
Hulu plus is only seven 99 per month.
Everybody all right,
less than a pack of cigarettes,
but right now they are offering an extended free trial of Hulu plus that is only
available to podcast listeners.
Take control of your TV watching experience.
Go to the podcast page at [inaudible] Dot Com and click on the Hulu plus banner
for your extreme extended free trial,
or go to Hulu plus.com/bill again,
that's Hulu plus banner on the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com or go to Hulu
plus.com/bill.
All right,
and believe it or not there,
I have to believe that's all the uh,
advertising,
right?
Is that right?
That I read them all?
Let's scroll through here.
Yes,
I did a righty.
Nothing but uh,
nothing but the jokes for the rest of the way.
All right,
let's read another letter.
Um,
where are we?
All right.
Hypocrisy of the female gender.
Oh Gee,
Jane.
Come on guys.
Come on ladies.
You know what?
Women trash the guys.
Let's have this fucking be balanced here.
Fair and balanced.
All right.
What do we got here?
Hypocrisy of the female gender.
My fucking,
my batteries are going to run out here.
I got to get through this one quickly.
Hey Bill,
Aka Aka bill Jizette shot during the summer.
That really has nothing to do with my name.
That's just sort of my first name and then a cum shot.
But you know,
you tried,
he goes,
I'm in a bit of a pickle.
Lacy got Jill's.
He's a Phallic Vegeta.
Is that a vegetable?
It's a pickle.
A vegetable or a fruit.
Well,
let's see.
Bill,
you're planting cucumbers.
Okay.
It's not on a tree.
It's in the ground.
It's a fucking vegetable.
Look at me and miss the fucking green jeans here.
Anyways.
Could be serious.
Could be just something that'll blow over.
But I'd like your opinion.
Anyway.
Um,
here we go.
A few days ago while I was getting a coffee,
I saw my girlfriend,
girlfriend's best friend,
kissing a dude that doesn't look like her boyfriend,
but like the rational human being that I am.
I thought I asked my girl before I jump to any conclusion.
So I asked her for boyfriend,
still her boyfriend?
She said yes and asked why?
So I told her what I saw and her reaction is something I didn't expect.
She went silent.
So I asked her if she already knew and said,
and she said yes and beg me not to tell the guy.
So I said that I'd like to hear your here,
the weight.
So I said that I'd like to hear the story first.
Oh my story first.
Okay.
I Dunno what the fuck.
Well,
I'm just going to read the way he wrote it.
So I said that,
I said that I'd like to hear the story first so I can assess hi.
I want to go about the situation.
I'm sorry.
And she refused.
So I said,
I guess it would be the same way if you were cheating on me.
Huh?
You would act the same way and you two would conspire over it.
And she denied that,
started crying and said she would never cheat on me.
Uh,
I told her it was fucking bullshit that she's implying that this can't have a
best friend,
has even the slightest legit reason to be a piece of shit.
And I eventually left to go get some air though.
It was difficult since she caused a scene and started screaming down the hall
from me.
I love when they do that.
Right.
Cause I mean the second a woman's starts screaming in public,
the guys like at the very least a borderline rapist.
Um,
all right.
Okay.
Well so far.
I,
you know,
I'm going to read,
just read the rest of it goes.
At that point she was breaking down crying and asked me to come back,
but I was fucking done.
The funny thing is about this,
the funny thing about this is I barely even know the guy.
I met him like twice.
He seems like a cool down to earth guy and all,
but I don't really owe him anything yet.
What's happening just triggers something in my mind and I feel like I should
tell him multiple people know his girlfriend is cheating on him and he has no
fucking clue.
I really lost a lot of respect for my girlfriend but she's always talks about
loyalty and how important it is to her and now she hates cheaters because she
knows how it feels to be on the other end.
What a fucking hypocrite.
When confronted with the situation head on.
She just excuses it and,
and mitigates it with secret.
Okay.
What mitigates it was secret court,
NSA legal reasoning.
So I have to believe.
Oh,
did it cut out?
Cutting out.
Hello?
Something sounds weird.
I think it's still taping,
right?
Oh Jesus.
All right.
Trying to read even faster here.
Um,
the fuck is going on with the sound now.
Hang on.
Hang on there.
We got back and I'll bet.
Um,
this is the worst read ever.
I'm sorry,
because this is a very interesting,
okay.
Uh,
I can't even look her,
look at her or talk to her right now.
Just thinking about the way she reacted to all of this still pisses me off.
So what should I do here?
Do I tell him?
I don't know.
Maybe I should just say fuck him.
You can't save the world.
Right?
And what about my girlfriend?
She's quick to say cheating's wrong until her and her group are on.
Are the ones doing the cheating?
Am I just slowly riding along this shit to eventually to eventual heartbreak?
Helped me out.
Bill,
you sexy based you.
Um,
all right,
well there's a lot of variables here.
Uh,
it's really the cheating girlfriend has put your girlfriend in a position
mmm.
Where she's dragged her into her shit.
You know,
where now she has to choose between her friendship to her and her feelings about
cheating and um,
okay.
I imagine it's her friend.
She loves her and she doesn't want to blow up her life.
MMM.
I Dunno.
I think,
I think what really needs to happen here is you don't need to get involved.
I think your girlfriend
needs to go to her girlfriend and tell her the situation that her cheating has
put herself in and that she needs to fucking end it
okay
with this other guy and grow up and start acting like a fucking adult because
they're pieces of shit.
Behavior is affecting your girlfriend's relationship and where you never had
trust issues.
You now do,
you know,
I'm not saying that your,
your,
your thoughts that your current girlfriend will now cheat on you are unfounded.
But there's two sides to loyalty to where you know,
you help your friend move a body,
you know,
there's people like that,
like,
you know,
just Jeter might be stringing your girlfriend along going,
I know,
I'm just confused right now.
I'm sorry.
I just need,
I feel like it needs something different,
but I still love Mike and I'm trying to,
I'm just doing a little Dick shopping.
I'm sorry I had to see it.
It's like the cock farmer's market,
whatever the fuck she saying.
Right.
Um,
okay.
Fuck her friend.
I feel bad for the other dude.
What are you going to do?
I would just sit down with your,
your,
your girlfriend and just be like,
look,
this is what happened.
This is what has to go down.
All right.
You don't,
whatever the fuck I just said,
you need to go talk to your girlfriend and tell her that she needs to fucking
clear up her situation because it's affecting my relationship.
Okay.
Grow Up,
break up with this other fucking guy,
you know,
and uh,
get on with your life.
That,
that's what I would suggest.
And,
um,
and,
but I don't think you're wrong to now be looking at your girlfriend.
Like what the fuck?
And a,
I never believe when a woman cries when you call them out on shit.
I never do because I don't believe the,
I don't believe the crying as a rule because they can cry on cue like Meryl
Streep,
you know,
um,
they just,
they just have access to that emotion and uh,
it automatically makes them the victim.
It makes you feel like you're a bully.
I think you're 100% right to feel the way you did a,
you might've gone at or a little too strong a and convenient option.
Uh,
I hope it works out for you.
Um,
in the meantime,
do you think you're going to marry this girl?
Because if you don't,
you're just wasting time.
And this is a great fucking a jump off point to get the fuck out of it.
You know,
NFL football starts next month,
that money is spending on her.
Going to the movies would look very nice with the NFL package.
You've got a lot of options here,
sir.
I'm good luck to you.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Thank you for everybody who came out to my shows.
I really appreciate it.
And thank you to everybody in the red state tour,
um,
for being patient.
I'm definitely getting out there.
I'm still bringing the t shirts.
I'm still doing the shows.
I'm just not doing them all at once.
Like I wanted to,
I don't get to drive across the great state of Montana,
but I get to see some of it.
I drive from Boise over,
um,
and I still get to go to deadwood.
I just have to figure out when I'm going to do it.
But I'm definitely coming and I apologize for the reschedule.
Just something beyond my control.
So I couldn't say no.
I had to do it mean,
I mean,
who the fuck am I?
Right?
I get eight lines in a movie.
I,
if I get a bigger part,
I got to take it.
All right.
So this is not the last time this will happen,
but I will promise you guys,
if I ever move a date,
I will always make it up.
I don't say,
Hey,
fuck that city,
cause I know how this business works.
You can get all the way up to win an Oscar and three years later you're in a
movie about talking babies.
All right?
I don't want to do that shit.
And if I fuck over Kansas City,
then they're not going to come out to my shows.
So I don't take you guys for granted.
All right?
And with that is the outro.
Now the show's over.
Don't forget to support our sponsors.
All the shit that I read this week get started with the a a free 30 day trial of
the voice gives you that toll free number.
He'd take care of business wherever you want.
So you sound like one of the big boys.
Um,
you can go to the podcast page,
click on the voice banner.
You got Hulu plus.
Start watching TV shows the way you want to right now.
Wherever the hell you want to watch it.
Watch entire episodes,
entire seasons,
you know everything.
But other than how the,
the frigging television was event invented.
Go to Hulu plus.com/belt or go to [inaudible] dot com uh,
on the podcast page and click on the Hulu plus banner.
And if you want high quality razors,
go to dollar shave club.com and that is it everybody.
That's the podcast for this week.
God bless you.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll talk to you next week.